Centre de Crise de prévention du suicide
bonjour problème conjugaux perte
d'emploi et des Noirs les centres de
crise comme celui-ci accueille une
clientèle qui sinon serait susceptible
d’engorger les hôpitaux surtout depuis
la pandémie on a surtout remarqué c'est
une augmentation de la détresse et de
l'intensité de la détresse ces
organismes n'ont pas été oubliés dans le
budget du Québec présenté hier sur plus
de 139 millions de dollars investis sur
cinq ans 25 millions serviront à
financer les centres de crise le même
montant sera consacré à l'aide aux
nouveaux parents plus de 76 millions
permettront de déployer des mesures pour
améliorer l'accès aux soins le reste
servira à réaliser des campagnes
d'information pour promouvoir ses
services un financement salué par les
intervenants en santé mentale même si
c'est loin d'être suffisant je suis pas
certaine que ça soit suffisant est-ce
que ça va couvrir tous les besoins je
pense pas la question du salaire qui
attirait contiendrait plus d'employés
est crucial selon le syndicat qui
représente ces travailleurs
aussi qui peuvent être en France là
en ayant des postes vacances Québec
promet de son côté de rehausser les
salaires dans la négociation actuelle on
veut faire une augmentation spéciale et
importante pour les psychologues la
présidente de la coalition des
psychologues du réseau public québécois
s'est entretenu aujourd'hui avec des
représentants du gouvernement nous
demande principale c'est de pouvoir
avoir une unité un syndicat de
psychologue et puis une augmentation de
la rémunération
significative pour freiner l'exode vers
le secteur privé qui était pharaon elle
dénote une ouverture de la part de
Québec mais rien de chiffrer
précise-t-elle pendant ce temps les
besoins sont criants plus 21.000
personnes sont en attente d'un service
en santé mentale et près de 200 se sont
ajoutés en une semaine seulement mais il
manque tellement de services que ça
prend du stratégie globale de
réinvestissement en santé mentale qui va
être beaucoup plus agressive selon
l'océde alors qu'en 2021 le Canada
consacré 10,6% de son budget en santé
mentale la France 15% et le Royaume-Uni
10,3%, le financement du ministre est
régirard ne représente que 6,3% des
dépenses additionnelles prévues moi je
pense que le plan est suffisamment
financé maintenant faut le réaliser on
souhaite poursuivre cette nos démarches
afin de développer encore plus nos
services Roxane Thibault compte sur de
futurs budgets pour bonifier son soutien
aux gens dans le besoin ici Élise alors
Radio-Canada Valleyfield